here's what we know so far about the  planes route flight k GL 9268 took off  from the Egyptian tourist resort of  Sharm el-sheikh just before six o'clock  this morning local time there were 224  people on board seven crew members 200  adult passengers and 17 children the  Russian operated airline was traveling  to some Petersburg but just 23 minutes  into the flight ground contact was lost  with the aircraft while it was flying  over the Sinai Peninsula the plane had  been traveling at an altitude of around  31,000 feet according to flight radar  the jet began to descend at a rate of  6,000 feet per minute just before it  lost signal the Egyptian authorities  have said their search and rescue teams  have found the wreckage of the crash  plane at the El hasnít area just south  of the city of Arish